you can't be acting like that bro yeah
well you can't be raping my kids
can you are you able to go somewhere
we're now getting a closer look at the
arrest of former Disney Channel star
Orlando Brown who was taken into custody
late last year after allegedly running
at a man with a hammer and knife blade I
don't want to go there else but he just
what do you do towards you I mean even
aggressive mode
on December 22nd police in Lima Ohio
responded
involving Brown and Matthew Sanders who
Brown referred to as his brother hey
guys what's going on
we're not doing anything so everybody
decided to come
yeah you can't be acting like that bro
yeah well you can't be raping my kids
I'm gonna let you talk to him okay you
want to talk to him so basically what's
going on here this man it's supposed to
be my for what to have her here
that's what he just said so what is he
to you I mean he's supposed to be my
brother he is your brother biological
brother
okay so that's basically what it is he
said he can call my wife
in a way not
waiting on her
so what would what would he have her
here for
to do whatever
well what will my wife come here for you
said you could have her here in five
minutes for you
to his house
oh yeah yes sir speaking to police
Sanders explains he's in business with
brown who he describes as a former Child
Star what's your relationship to him
um we were in business
um like I said he's an actor I'm
shooting a movie what's his first name
Orlando
Brown
you ever seen major pain yeah that's him
the little kid
oh is that right yeah that's a raven
that's him too Sanders says Brown was
facing life in a homeless shelter so he
took the actor in
it's a long back story but everybody was
going to be homeless I was like no don't
be homeless bro here I got a house and
I'm sure stay here until then till you
figure it out but Sanders said he needed
police assist s after Brown allegedly
came after him with a hammer and a knife
blade
if he pulled a knife and hammer on you
you could be charged with domestic
violence
okay
well that's where I gotta go I don't
want to go there but he just had a knife
okay what what do you do towards you I
mean aggressive mode
thrusting it forward for us and all of
that okay but I did filter it okay
for my safety
it was that box cutter up there that
there's a knife on the bottom over here
underneath that cardboard box let's go
and look at that stuff official explain
to standards that brown can't easily be
kicked out of the home
hey you want to talk to me what's going
on
[Music]
um
she's in here going crazy about my house
that says him this is okay he doesn't
live here I let him stay here because
he's going to a homeless shelter about a
month ago I thought I could help him he
said why I can't just trying to get him
back on Dr Phil he's got to go I can't
do that how long have we been staying
here he doesn't have no mail coming here
I'll probably talked to my lawyer none
of that he's been staying here for a
little while okay
well it gives us I know you've been
talking to your lawyer but they're not
going to let us just boot them out well
it's already pulled a camera on me he's
pulled a knife out on me just today yeah
right now okay you want to file charges
on him no I don't want to file charges
on him but he can't be here no more okay
well we can't you're gonna have to go to
civil courts they might give you an
emergency affection you need to tell
them everything that he's doing okay
he's not paying renting like that I know
like it's if somebody
I understand your frustration but we
can't as police officers go in there and
say hey man you got to go because you
said he's been here for a little bit but
let's say I let a friend stay in my
house for a little bit you're just on
the couch it's been three four five days
I'm screwed okay they're the landlord
tenant laws are I mean the squatter laws
are even worse in Ohio
okay so I'll go up the line Municipal
Court what I'm saying he's going to
destroy my health if he stays in here
okay but we can't force him out
well then uh okay
so I'll leave it like that then okay so
I'll go up to the Civil course get the
ball roll on the key or anything either
I understand it's just a strict law now
we would be we'd be breaking the law
office today man you gotta go
so there's a way to do it you just got
to go up to the Civil courts live
Municipal Court second floor okay I'll
go up there immediately you might be
able to get emergency eviction they can
explain all that stuff to him
victim
emergency eviction is there other family
members anywhere he can stay
hold on
yeah for you say thank you to come here
for you
um can you are you able to go somewhere
are you able to go somewhere
huh
I don't got no spaces
once you go back and talk to him oh yeah
yes sir you want to show me what he's
been doing inside
um
the house is here
this same interaction is shown from
other angles as brown talks about his
wife and tells officers he's been out
the house for almost a month
to his house
oh yeah yes sir
um
the house is
here
[Music]
this is where I've been living at this
is where I've been for the last past
like what six days 12 Days
a whole month almost where does your
wife live at in Texas
after that brown is taken into custody
no problem
out of here
can I talk to him real quick yeah we
we're gonna go okay
all right yeah
hey Dad
hey that's what's up appreciate it all
right thank you
everyone will get you up there okay
while being transported to the Allen
County Jail Brown can be heard speaking
to officer Mark link
oh I'm doing okay man you oh I'm
straight y'all saved my life
I'm sorry man
you know
all right 44.
like y'all made a collective decision
guys
well it's what he had said to us that
the other officers determined that it's
domestic violence
apparently he said he told the other
officers that you come out in with the
hammer in with a knife
with a hammer and a knife yes under and
under Ohio law that constitute since you
guys are brothers that constitutes
domestic violence
word not my blood
I I you told me that you were brothers
yeah I mean this is his City I wouldn't
come out here for nobody
link explains what's next for brown so
what's going to happen is you'll go to
the county jail for domestic violence
threats okay
and he will have the opportunity to go
tomorrow to file charges against you
if he doesn't go you'll be released
tomorrow about 10 A.M
if he does file charges against you
um
you'll have a hearing tomorrow at two
o'clock to bond hearing with the judge
okay
so it all depends and if he wants to
file charges or not
oh
body camera video also captures Sanders
telling First Responders he didn't want
to press charges but just wants Browns
to get help
so he does have
history mental illness
uh my knowledge is on Dr Phil Jesse said
they put him in creative care and
Sierra okay uh past filing Behavior yes
okay does he abuse the drugs or alcohol
um
I pre-book it
all right that's all I need for now
like I said tomorrow we'll have to file
the charges
and like I was trying to say earlier
just because filing charges doesn't mean
you're putting him in jail but it can
also give him Court mandated treatment
and in the end that's what we we wanted
to be a better person no that's the goal
that's why I really thought I can help
him man but he's out of my control I
can't Brown was originally charged with
aggravated menacing but that was later
downgraded to criminal damaging and
endangering he eventually pleaded guilty
to that charge and was fined fifty
dollars plus court fees reporting for a
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie